[Music]
around three million women have served
our country in the military including
168 who died in the wars in Iraq and
Afghanistan there is a place in
Arlington Virginia where female vets are
honored it's called the women and
military service for America memorial on
this Memorial Day Jan Crawford takes us
there to remember the Fallen and meet
some of the Living heroes who served
alongside them their work is the stuff
of legend their service to the nation
unmistakable the women in the service
were really there to help win the war
but the contributions and stories of
women veterans like 90 year-old Kiki
Chappell often are overlooked and that's
what this unique memorial at the gateway
to Arlington National Cemetery is
designed to help change it tells the
stories of veterans like Chapelle who
recently visited for the first time I
had been doing war work Rosie the
Riveter and things like that and I felt
that I wanted to do something more
directly connected with winning the war
Chapelle joined the Navy as an airplane
repair technician during World War two
despite being underage she lied about
her age because she knew serving in the
military could change her life the Navy
gave me a marvelous opportunity to do
things I would never have been able to
do she went on to earn a master's degree
in engineering through the GI Bill
eventually building airplanes at
Lockheed Martin she credits joining the
military the foundation was from my Navy
service it was the smartest decision I
ever made
but for Chappell and other women serving
in the 1940s it wasn't easy
the women came back from World War two
and they were sold thank you for your
service go home
Major General Diane McWilliams oversees
the memorial says its mission is to
preserve the stories of women like
Chappell struggles and their sacrifices
because of what she did and the nurses
of World War one did was like a bill
blocks that would tell our nation these
women can do it all of these stories are
gathered here in this race they are yes
and each one is unique and and personal
so personal McWilliams says it's her
goal to have all women who have served
or are serving included in the register
every story is unique and they're
important not just to them their family
but to our nation for chapelle the world
war two displays brought back memories
of a time that changed her life
this uniform appeared the last couple
months of the war and all of a sudden we
had something different to wear all of
this a way to remember their service and
preserve their life stories for future
generations I see a great deal of
progress now there are plenty of women
of high achievement in the military and
I'm proud of them for CBS this morning
Jan Crawford Washington I love Kiki
story right one impressive lady thanked
incredible yeah to Lockheed Martin you
having planes it's such a beautiful
story and certainly we think about those
168 women who gave their lives in Iraq
and Afghanistan all the others who have
done so as well but what a beautiful
story